TREY: WELCOME BACK, TO
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN AMERICA,"
MAYBE I WAS WRONG TO BE
SURPRISED.
FIVE GOP MEMBERS OF HOUSE
REMAIN CONVINCED YOU CAN WIN
'PRESIDENCY, YET YOU CAN
LOSE THE SPEAKER'S RACE WITH
85% OF THE VOTE.
SO MUCH FOR RESPECTING THE
WILL OF THE VOTERS AND MATH.
G.O.P. HOUSE SAID CHANCE
COME JANUARY TO SHOW THEY
CAN GOVERN AND PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, TO STOP
LITIGATION INITIATED BY
NANCY PELOSI, BUT NONE OF
THAT WILL BE DONE UNLESS
THERE IS A SPEAKER.
FIVE GOP MEMBERS OF HOUSE
WILL NOT SUPPORT THE WINNER
OF PRIMARY, NOMINEE OF THE
PARTY.
WHO DO THEY WANT?
THEY ARE THE REASON THAT
COMMITTEES HAVE NOT BEEN
POPULATED OR CHAIR PERSONS
SELECTED.
TIME IS OF ESSENCE IF NEW
G.O.P. HOUSE WANTS TO SHOW
COUNTRY IT CAN LEAD.
JOINING US NOW IS THE MAN
WHO GOT 85 PERCENT OF THE
VOTE CONGRESSMAN KEVIN
McCARTHY, YOU WON THE
PRIMARY IN OVERWHELMING
FASHION.
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE THERE ARE
A FEW OUT THERE THAT DOWN
DON'T WANT TO HONOR THE
RESULTS OF THAT ELECTION, SO
OUR VIEWERS ARE CLEAR, TWO
PEOPLE RAN IN NOVEMBER.
YOU GOT 85 PERCENT AND ANDY
BIGS GOT 15% OF THE VOTE.
>> THEY DON'T SAY WHO THEY
HAVE, WHAT IS HARMING IS THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC, WE WERE
TRUSTED WITH MAJORITY TO
KEEP BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IN
CHECK, WE WENT THROUGH TWO
ELECTION CYCLES SINCE I HAVE
BEEN LEADER, EVERY ELECTION
CYCLE WE HAVE WON SEATS, BUT
BAD PART OTHER REPUBLICANS
HAVE LOST, GOVERNORS, SENATE
AND PRESIDENT, BUT WE WON,
THIS IS DELAYING OUR ABILITY
FOR FIRST DAY TO REPEAL 87
THOUSAND IRS AGENTS, YOU
HAVE TITLE 42 LIFTED NEXT
WEEK, MORE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER.
WE WANT TO HAVE HEARINGS AT
THE BORDER, AND SECURE THE
BORDER, HOW DO WE MAKE
OURSELVES
ENERGY-INDEPENDENT, WE CAN'T
DO ANYTHING UNTIL WE ELECT
THE SPEAKER.
TREY: YOU IN 2010 HELPED
RETAKE GAVEL FROM NANCY
PELOSI.
YOU HAVE DONE IT AGAIN NOW,
THAT IS TWICE YOU HAVE BEEN
PART OF RECAPTURING
MAJORITY.
I KNOW YOU PRETTY WELL, I
DOUBT YOU SPENT ANY TIME
DOING THIS, BUT DO YOU HAVE
ANY IDEA HOW MANY DISRICKS
-- DISTRICTS YOU VISITED,
TIME YOU SPENT AWAY FROM
CALIFORNIA TO HELP RETAKE
THE MAJORITY.
>> I'LL SAY, SINCE LAST
AUGUST TO THIS ELECTION I
WENT TO 41 STATES AND
CAMPAIGNED WITH 170 MEMBERS
AND CANDIDATES, YOU HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO WIN THE MAJORITY.
YOU HAVE TO GET MESSAGE OUT,
YOU UNITE PEOPLE AROUND IT
AND BE ABLE TO WIN.
WE WON WHEN EVERY OTHER
REPUBLICAN LOST, THE
UNIQUENESS, YOU KNOW THIS
THEY DON'T HAND GAVELS OUT
IN SMALL, MEDIUM OR LARGE,
THEY GIVE YOU ONE GAVEL AND
THE POWER OF THE SUBPOENA.
TO HOLD THIS ADMINISTRATION
IN CHECK, YOU KNOW WHO SIGNS
OFF ON THAT, THE SPEAKER,
NOTHING CAN GO FORWARD
WITHOUT GETTING THIS DONE,
ALL LAWSUIT THAT NANCY
PELOSI STARTED IN THE HOUSE
CONTINUE AGAINST
REPUBLICANS WHILE WE'RE
SITTING IN THE MAJORITY IF
WE DON'T SOLVE THIS.
TREY: SPEAKING OF GAVELS,
THE 5 ARE SPENDING MORE
ENERGY TRYING TO KEEP YOU
FROM GETTING THE GAFFE OLD
THAN THEY DID TAKING IT OUT
OF HANDS OF NANCY PELOSI,
THEY HAVE A LOT OF ENERGY
THEY HAVE
INVESTED AGAINST A FELLOW
REPUBLICAN, DON'T COMMENT ON
THAT, YOU ARE NOT HITTING
GROUND RUNNING ON JANUARY 3
UNTIL YOU HAVE A SPEAKER
WHAT IS AT STAKE.
>> A LOT.
FIRST GETTING THIS COUNTRY
ON TRACK, STOPPING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, SECURING THE
BORDER, AND ENERGY
INDEPENDENT, PASSING A
PARENT'S BILL OF RIGHTS AND
REPEALING THE 87,000 I.R.S.
AGENTS AND HOLDING THE
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY HAVE DELAYED US A
COUPLE OF MONTHS FROM, THAT
WE DON'T HAVE STAFF YET, WE
DON'T HAVE COMMITTEES
POPULATED;  IF WE CONTINUE
TO GO AROUND THIS MORN
LIKE THIS, FBI CONTINUES TO
DO WHAT THEY ARE DOING FOR
TWITTER AND OTHERS, WE FIND
OUT WHAT IS GARLAND DOING.
LET'S GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THE PROBLEM THAT HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING, UNITED AND MOVE
BEYOND THIS.
YOU ARE RIGHT WE DID HAVE A
PRIMARY, AFTER THE ELECTION,
WE ALL HAD A MEETING, A LOT
OF THEM TALK ABOUT WANTING
TO EMPOWER THE MEMBERSHIP
MORE, WHY WOULDN'T THEY
RESPECT WHAT THE MEMBERSHIP
VOTED OWHY NOT RESPECT 85%
OF THE VOTE.
TREY: WELL, KEVIN, I'M
GETTING FINED BY FCC IF I
SAY WHAT IS ON MY MIND, I
WILL SAY, I
HOPE YOU HAVE A VERY MERRY
CHRISTMAS, WE'LL WATCH ON
JANUARY 3 TO SEE WHETHER OR
NOT WINNING A PRIMARY WITH
85% OF THE VOTE MATTERS ANY
MORE, UNTIL THEN HAVE A
FANTASTIC WEEK BEFORE
CHRISTMAS, AND THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US ON A SUNDAY
NIGHT.
>> MER